I am just incredibly humbled,
blessed.
♪ (HIP HOP MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
You aspire a dream I never
imagined I would get
to work with so many amazing,
talented people.
You guys have elevated me.
(CHEERING)
PRENTICE PENNY: Working
in television for a long time
and not being able to see
people that looked like me,
to be able to do a show
like that now
sets the groundwork that people
want to make more shows like us
is just really special.
I put in all elements
of my life,
so I can say this is rooted
in authenticity,
and they were like,
"Okay, green light."
NATASHA ROTHWELL: For people
of color in this industry,
the fear of failure is so real
because we don't get
that many opportunities.
This show has been part
of the revolution.
The way you showcase
our beautiful,
Black full humanity,
it's part of the revolution.
We all owe so much to you.
JAY ELLIS: It's rare to go
to work every day
and love every single person
we've had on our production.
It's all you can dream for.
-That's a wrap.
-(CHEERING)